[Music]
is in blue the PIA transmissions try to
keep us all down we never see the truth
no the promise another sea
but that could like to keep the champion
a green box wrapped around on my
red tape to keep the truth in 2012 after
the release of Mass Effect 3 an
ambitious project codenamed Dylan was
undertaken by the Bioware team June 2017
a new title was announced at e3 showing
never-before-seen gameplay footage
described by Bioware as a new game from
EAS Bioware studio will you explore a
landscape of primeval Beauty confront
the dangers you find and grow in power
with every step with similarities to
titles like destiny and the division the
game immediately started generating hype
among the gaming community considered by
EA to be the evolution of a Bioware game
that doesn't neglect story content in a
multiplayer game but instead integrates
them together in a shared open-world due
to be released February 2019 I'd like to
cover everything we know about the story
so far regarding the savage it's
stunningly beautiful world of anthem
[Music]
the creators or gods known simply as the
shapers set out to build the world in
nine days but on day three suddenly went
wrong and the shape is vanished the
anthem of creation or anthem for short
is a powerful force and the source of
pure creation the shapers used massive
instruments to tap into this force and
create the world but when the shape has
disappeared they lift their instruments
behind these devices can be found
littered across the landscape however
just because the shape is of lift
doesn't mean that the discarded tools
are just an active artifacts spread
across the world the shaper technology
is responsible for the creation of the
world but also for the constant
devastating effects that reshape the
environment surrounding them these
ancient relics continue to tap into the
echoes of the anthem of creation and
activate at random causing a constant
state of change across the world they
not just create life but they also
mutate existing life including the
transformation of the earth itself the
climate of the world is unforgiving and
every animal that lives on it is hostile
to humans for tarsus is a compound that
shields humanity from the dangers of the
outside world it's protected by
automated turrets and a huge structure
called the wall fort asus is essentially
a fortified city where humans can reside
safely away from the outside world
the history of fort Tarsus traces back
500 years ago to a general Hellena
tarsus leader of the Legion of dawn this
group created and piloted the first
javelin exosuits
it was these people that lead mankind
into a place of security and safety
through their bravery and hard work
humanity was able to build the
stronghold settlements safe from the
dangers of the outside world in present
day humanity is scattered across a
number of settlements they have been
pushed to the brink attempting to hold
out against the constantly changing
animals of the world and hostile
factions
over time a group splintered off from
the Legion of dawn and became their own
affection this faction was later known
as the freelancers although technically
they aren't military they carry on the
Legion of dawn traditions of protecting
the people freelancers a task for
dealing with the threats outside of the
city walls these days the freelancers
aren't seen as the heroes that there
once were at one point there were the
saviors of society and brought humanity
back when times were dark today this
scene is more of a contractor often
hiring out the services to one of the
many various factions at fort Asus
freelancers have access to the most
advanced technology that humanity has
available
javelins javelins are powered exosuits
that grant the wear of superhuman like
capabilities these were first created by
the Legion of dawn by reverse
engineering shaper technology javelins
today are pieced together using various
parts that are found allowing the
freelancer to build this suit to fit
their individual needs javelins are not
readily available as resources to
construct them are difficult to come
across they're passed down from one
generation to the next and are generally
a source of admiration as not everyone
can pilot one of these suits and those
that do are some of the few they're able
to leave the safety of the fort Asus
ciphers are another faction that live at
Fort Asus these humans are gifted with
telepathy ciphers are trained in the
ability to communicate over long
distances performing complex analytical
calculations and processing large
amounts of information they serve as a
support role for freelancers providing
information in analysis while out on
missions strapped into an amplifier
chair safely behind city walls ciphers
are able to assist freelancers with
their long-range weaponry and with
scanning the environment for threats
[Music]
so other than the fact that the whole
world is trying to kill humanity not
just the animals on it but the world
itself there is also a number of hostile
factions that need to watch out for
ancient enemies of the freelancers the
Dominion is a militaristic group of
humans that have been aggressively
conquering the north the Dominion aimed
to control shape and technology and
harness the power of anthem through
weaponizing anthem they hope to be able
to establish their rule over the rest of
the world but through their tampering
with the shape of Technology they're
putting everyone at risk like the
freelancers the Dominion have access to
Jeff lands the scars are a non-human
invasive force not from this world
originally they arrived using shaper
technology and seem to have some sort of
connection to the shapers the scars are
here to claim the shaper technology but
as this is something that the
freelancers are trying to stop factions
from doing due to the relics
unpredictable and devastating nature
they're currently hostile towards each
other months from release we currently
only have so much information to read
into right now but one thing is certain
they've created quite an interesting and
potentially high depth foundation for
the story the world has an alluring and
mysterious vibe to it and through the
gameplay we've seen so far it certainly
gives you the feeling of being quite a
powerful hero of humanity my concerns
towards this game when it was first
announced was that it was similar enough
to destiny to be compared to it
historically Bioware has been pretty
strong with this story characters and
loot system but they really didn't
reveal much about the builds versity
side of things
so if it was to be successful it needed
to be a damn good shooter which is where
the dystiny team has had a lot more
experience in success over the years
however the feedback from people who
have managed to play the demo at e3 all
state that the movement combat system
and shooting mechanics are fluid and
generally just feel right it's all
rumors aside I'm starting to feel
quietly optimistic about anthem and I
can't wait to dig a little deeper as the
majority of my viewers are predominantly
from the division what are your thoughts
about anthem looking forward to it let
me know in the comments below as per
usual I've been your host Joe from
Indian Gaming or awkward Kiwi accent guy
you know what it works Cheers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you